hello everyone a lot of you have seen
this game already because it's well
probably the most famous game ever
played but the chests community is
growing and a lot of new players are
starting to play chess every day and
well it would be a shame not to show
this game on my channel this was played
in 1858 and it was played while Paul
Morphy was visiting Paris he was 21
years old at the time and he got an
invitation from the Duke of Brunswick to
come see come see the Opera with him it
was it was an Italian opera called Norma
and since mafia was really into music he
accepted the offer but by accepting the
offer to the Opera he also accepted his
challenge to play against him and his
companion account his art and okay more
figure out to the Opera and they started
to play but for the entire game when
Morphy was seated at the board they had
their own private box which was above
the stage morphic was actually facing to
the stage with his backhand for the
entire game or if it was actually trying
to watch it short so he had to look back
to see what was going on in the play and
so when one might say that morphe
actually played this game blindfolded as
well he could have probably so Paul
Morphy is white and Duke and count are
black we have E for buy more fee and E 5
Knight to f3 d6 the Philidor defense
Morphy plays d4 occupying the center and
now Bishop to g4 and this Bishop to g4
move it was considered standard theory
at the time but today it's considered to
be a bad move as if if why simply plays
D captures an e5 and black responds with
it captures and D flat D captures an e5
and then simply Queen captures on d8
with check King capture son d8 and now
simply Knight captures on e5 and this
one's upon also threatening here to
attack the bishop and also threatening
the the pawn on f7 so after morphe
played D captures on e5 the two the two
opponents decided to play Bishop
captures on f3 so Murphy played Queen
captures on f3 and now black is still
down a pawn and he plays D captures on
e5 and Murphy plays Bishop to c4
developing nicely also with
of checkmate on f7 so black has to
defend this they play Knight to f6
defending and now more if he plays Queen
to b3 now attacking again f7 and also b7
and well both threats cannot be defended
as so black plays 27 out defending this
f7 threat and steinitz here and also
Lasker after him and a lot of other
players have said that more if you
should have played a queen capture some
b7 here and that this is the strongest
move but that's just the thing
Queen captures on b7 is a butcher's move
and the Morphy was an artist not a
butcher so Murphy plays Knight to c3
again going for rapid development
instead of material
we'd have c6 now the queen is protecting
this b7 pawn and we have Bishop g5 by
Murphy also going for rapid development
and now b5 attacking this Bishop and
forcing him to move from this strong
diagonal and the threat of f7 but here
morphe doesn't retreat with the bishop
instead he plays Knight captures on b5
offering a knight so C capture son b5
and now Bishop captures on b5 with check
and well there's really not a lot of
ways black can defend against this check
this knight is pinned from the bishop so
he can't really go anywhere if the King
goes to d8 then simply a queen said
castle with check and this is completely
winning so black tries a knight Knight
to the Knight B to d7 and Morphy just
plays a queenside castle and now this
Knight is attacked with the bishop and
the rook and also this Knight is kind of
protecting it but it's really not
because it's pinned so we have Brooke to
the 8th now defending that night and
Morphy just plays rook captures on d7
rod captures and e7 and now place the
other rook to d1 and now this rook is
attacked also twice and well white is
completely winning in this position but
black tries tries a free move they
decide to play Queen to e6 and also now
now threatening to exchange Queens and
also now this night isn't pinned anymore
so the rook is captured the knight can
simply recapture it but this actually
allows morphe to finish finish the
gaming in great style more few plays
Bishop captures and e7 which
check and now of course the knight can
capture because it's not pinned anymore
we have a knight capture son d7 and now
a beautiful finishing move by morphe
Queen Queen to be a check and black work
is without a move the King can't go
anywhere only move black asses to accept
the Queen sacrifice with tonight capture
Sun b8 and morphe finishes the game with
rook to d8 checkmate and you can see
this beautiful mating picture it's
probably the most famous mating picture
in the entire chess history where black
white only has a bishop and g5 and the
rook candiate but that's that's all it
takes
so yeah and it's it's a beautiful game
and it's a great example of how how
rapid development is preferred to being
materialistic and it's also a very nice
story how more if you played this entire
game while actually trying to play it
trying to watch the Opera that he hadn't
seen before and he's he's also playing
against two players who were who are
actually speaking in three different
languages just to confuse Morphy so he
wouldn't understand them but it didn't
do them much much good so yeah I do hope
you enjoyed this game and as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
I thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon